Earlier this year, the bracket system
was rolled out in the commander format,
providing guidelines for separating
decks into different rough groupings to
be played together. Soon after, though,
I noticed a problem. I didn't have any
bracket 2 decks. I had a lovely variety
of different bracket 3 decks from battle
cruiser to aggro to control to low slung
staxi mid-range, but nothing I'd feel
comfortable consistently pulling out in
games against three precons or
equivalent decks. At least not without
the expectation of playing a 1v3
archeneemy sort of role. So, that seemed
like a problem worth remedying. Now, I
had built a lower power deck in the
past. A couple years previously, I'd
built a skeleton ship proliferate deck,
and that was kind of funny, but it was
lower power purely because it ran a hot
garbage commander and a number of hot
garbage cards in the 99, such as Shrine
of Piercing Vision, Mindless Automaton,
Time Bomb, and a whole four of the '90s
storage lands that couldn't tap for
non-stored mana. It was funny, but the
play pattern was jarring with the deck
being glacially slow to get going, but
potentially quite oppressive in the late
game if it was left alone to fully build
up an engine. You can probably imagine
why I mostly stopped playing this deck.
One alternative for having a bracket 2
deck would be just buying a precon and
maybe doing a slight round of upgrades
or sidegrades, but I wanted something
that felt more my own than that. There's
also another problem with both precons
and the skeleton ship deck. They feel
kind of sub-optimal. This probably
sounds like a very silly criticism of a
deck intended to play in relatively low
power games, but I really like the
process of tightening up a deck's
cohesion, of finding the perfect cards
for its mechanical needs. The process of
turning a deck into a machine that does
something. I like that process, and I
like to play decks that feel like
they're performing the role I want them
to perform as well as they can.
Immediately, this is a bit of a
conflict. This preference for
optimization works fine for bracket 3
because there are a whole lot of
somewhat funky ideas whose optimized
version ends up in that sort of nice
midpower zone. But bracket 2 is harder.
What sort of idea is so inherently
mediocre that optimizing it ends up at
the power level of a precon? In this
case, I actually took inspiration from
precons themselves. See, preconstructed
commander decks are typically unfocused
by design. They feature slightly too
many themes and elements because they're
trying to give players a taste of
different play styles and also give some
easy paths to upgrade a given deck, such
as cutting a singular sub theme for some
more relevant stuff. So, what if I did
the same thing but on overdrive? What if
I built a deck with way too many sub
themes, like a truly irresponsible
number of sub themes, and then tried my
hardest to optimize it into a workable
deck list? Thus began the process of
building Farrexian flavored subthe soup.
Longtime snail heads out there might
remember that I hated Glista Sunslayer
battle cruiser deck a while back. And
while I love Glysa as a character, both
that deck and that Glyissa ran a bit
generic for my tastes. Glya the traitor
could be fun as an old school sort of
commander choice, but that one is
actually a bit too specific for my
purposes here with a setup and payoff
that don't offer a super wide variety of
options. However, there's another green
black option, and that one actually
lands right in the sweet spot for me.
Glya, Herold of Predation. This is a
five mana 35 that offers a choice at the
beginning of combat on your turn.
Incubate two twice, flip all of your
incubator tokens, or give your Forexians
first strike and death touch until end
of turn. Incubate as a mechanic is
pretty unique. It creates a non-creature
artifact token with plus one plus1
counters on it that can later be flipped
into a Forexian artifact creature by
paying two mana. Obviously, this lends
itself to a deck that cares about
counters. So, we'll call that sub theme
number one. But honestly, the first
thing I noticed about this glitza is
wow, this card generates a lot of
artifact tokens. There's a number of
fairly straightforward ways to take
advantage of having artifact tokens.
Cards like Terrion's Journal and
Aviscerator's Insight sacrifice
artifacts to draw. Monumental Corruption
can either be a big draw spell or a
player killing spell depending on the
artifact count. And Throne of Gath is a
potent one card engine with the
commander, also boosting the counter
theme. So, for our purposes here, having
a lot of artifacts is subthe number two,
and it's one of the more central themes
here. It also contains arguably the
deck's most powerful card and one that
inspired much of the rest of the list,
Clock of Omens. This is a four- mana
artifact that allows a player to tap two
artifacts to untap a different artifact.
And while it's not quite a combo piece
here, I think it still has the potential
for some big turns. The most basic
version of that is with some of my
bigger counterbased mana rocks.
Repeatedly tapping and untapping
Everflowing Chalice, Astral Cornucopia,
or Empowered Auto Generator can really
push the deck's mana into new territory
and let it do some big plays. There are
a lot of other options as well, though.
Idol of Oblivion for card draw, Staff of
Completion for Proliferates and more,
and both Twitching Doll and Lux Cannon
as cool cards that also use counters.
The deck contains a couple other options
for untapping, but it does sometimes run
into a problem. Not all of the cool tap
abilities I want to run and repeat are
on artifacts. I have cards like Plaguema
Beast and White of the Requary that take
advantage of my tokens, and I'd quite
like to activate them repeatedly after
flipping a bunch of incubators with
Glysa. So, what if I just turned them
into artifacts? Enter the Liquid Metal
package. This features Liquid Metal
Torque and Farrexian Scriptures, both
cards that turn a quizure into an
artifact creature, as well as being a
manor and a boardweight, respectively.
This package also contains two other
cards, and these are actually my two
favorite cards in the deck, Dollhouse of
Horrors and Nexus of Becoming. Both of
these cards create token copies of cards
that are also artifact creature
constructs with Dollhouse doing this by
exiling creatures from the graveyard and
Nexus doing this by exiling artifacts or
creatures from a player's hand. The
downside of exiling the copied card is
certainly real, but the potential volume
of liquid creature creation is really
potent here. And due to a particular
quirk of these cards, they're able to
form the bedrock for yet another one of
the deck sub themes, token copy
populate. Since the artifact creature
copies created by Nexus and Dollhouse
are tokens, they can be further copied
by cards like Celelesnia eulogist and
Esus chariot cards that copy tokens.
This can allow for some nutty levels of
advantage building. And to improve the
odds for things to come together, I
threw in a few extra token copy
generators as well. This still isn't a
huge package, just five setup and four
payoff, but most of these cards are fine
enough on their own, and the payoff for
putting them together can be pretty
huge. A late addition to this deck was a
graveyard sub theme. I adore Dollhouse
of Horrors, and on paper, it's perfect
for this deck, but too often in my early
games, I was finding myself without much
to do with it, making copies of maybe
one or two creatures, but not feeling
like I was getting anywhere close to the
full potential of the card. This was
also my experience with another card I
like, Vat of Rebirth. So, I decided to
help these cards out with the addition
of some other graveyard payoffs, and
especially some more graveyard enablers.
I went with mostly flexible options
here. Milikin as a card that's also a
manador. Sarinth steelseeker as a sort
of value engine that works well with my
artifact tokens. Old rustine as a card
that also itself pushes my tokens plan.
And Tyar as a planaineswalker that also
ties into activated abilities. Okay, so
with the graveyard package covered,
we've capped off the list of all the
major sub themes, but there are a few
more minor packages as well. The deck
runs a constructs package with scrapyard
recombiner, which gives it access to a
removal spell and a few synergy options
of different calibers. There's also five
cards that create power stones, which
can pay for one of the next 31
artifacts, one of the deck's 23 cards
with a colorless mana payable activated
ability, or any one of the incubator
tokens Gissa makes. For the weirdest
little tidbit here, the deck can
actually populate incubator tokens. This
might seem bad since the copy won't
enter with counters and will instantly
die when flipped or instantly instantly
if it's already on the creature side,
but this actually allows for ondemand
usage of ondeath trigger cards like draw
scorpion and morbid opportunist without
needing a sack outlet. Sort of like
aristocrats without the aristocrats, I
guess. So, this deck kind of does a
little bit of everything. And all of
that everything is anchored by Glysa.
The artifact tokens she provides
certainly are a big help for sacrificing
and whatnot, but the biggest thing Glya
does is provide the deck with a reliable
windcon. Typically, I'll try to ramp out
Glissel on turn four and start gradually
accumulating incubators. Maybe
sacrificing one here or there. Once
that's up and chugging, I can just focus
on cobbling together whatever stupid
little engine I have the tools to
create. Whether that be a value engine,
a ramp engine, a removal engine, or some
combination of these things. What's
important is that I eventually find my
way to some proliferate, at which point
I can use my resource advantage to
amplify the counters on my accumulated
tokens before having Glysa flip them,
allowing me to swing big at an opponent.
The fact that such an absurdly complex
and multifaceted deck typically wins by
swinging in with a bunch of vanilla 66s
is a pretty juicy morsel of irony, and
it really lets the deck feel truly
belonging in bracket 2. And actually,
this feature about the deck is part of
what helps it stay comfortably bracket
2. In theory, this deck has some gross
plays. First of all, there's an infinite
mana combo that involves popping out
empowered autogenerator as a creature
with Nexus of Becoming before repeatedly
untapping it with Voltaic Construct the
following turn. It's a rather strange
one and requires a non-trivial amount of
setup, but it still is a three-card
infinite combo. In addition, the deck
features some pretty powerful cards like
Clock of Omens, Kudo the Forgemaster,
and Staff of Completion, and these can
help the deck assemble some pretty
disgusting engines. Despite this, I have
not once had a win with this deck that
didn't heavily involve Kissa, and that
puts a natural cap on things. As long as
she's out, I get two incubators per
turn, but that's all I get. I can make
them bigger, in some cases a lot bigger
if I have a proliferate engine really
pop off, but I'm still going to be
winning the game with a fairly ordinary
and extremely predictable number of most
likely vanilla creatures. So, that's the
deck, and I do find it quite fun, but I
worry that the process of describing it
might be making it seem a bit more
functional than it actually is. A deck
that tries to cram in as many sub themes
as possible is naturally going to
struggle with dead cards when the cards
intended to work with those cards decide
not to show up. The only deck I have
that comes even close to this one in
terms of complexity is my Sharon deck,
but there's a pretty clear difference
between these two. That deck is a
toolbox deck that runs 11 conditional
tutors to help it piece together
engines, whereas this deck has two
tutors. I don't know if there's been an
exact tutor limit given for bracket 2,
but I've heard the number three floated
around and that felt like a nice number
to shoot for here that would force some
creative workarounds without being an
outright barrier against tutoring. All
this to say, with the daring vision and
self-imposed restrictions I had going
into this deck, dead cards were
inevitably going to be a challenge. So,
how does this deck mitigate that? A big
one is that I try pretty hard not to let
a card perform only one task for the
deck. There is no generic removal here.
When I highlight the cards in my
interaction suite that proliferate, use
counters or are lands in architect. That
excludes only five cards and all of
those either fit into another sub theme
or have some sort of useful synergy in a
removal engine. The same goes for ramp.
Of the next 19 cards that perform some
sort of ramp function, the two most
generic are Golgari Signant and Talisman
of Resilience, with every single other
one evolving counters, producing power
zones, or otherwise slotting into one of
the deck's themes. Likewise for draw,
with morbid opportunist being by far the
most generic of the deck's 17 sources of
value. And that's even considering the
weird populate trick I mentioned
earlier. Something else you might notice
here is that the number of ramp and draw
spells are fairly high. And this is
another pretty essential feature for
letting the deck run smoothly. Since
there are singledigit counts of setup
and payoff for a number of different sub
themes throughout the deck, it becomes
very important to see more of the deck
in order to piece together engines. I
actually bought a couple draw engines on
the convention floor at Magic on Vegas
because I was noticing some light
stallouts in the games I was playing.
And sure enough, that helped out the
deck quite a bit. This also applies to
ramp since there's no guarantee that the
lowcost cards I have available will be
what I'm looking for in a given moment.
Having some extra ramp to let me use
activated abilities and more expensive
cards instead also contributes a bit of
flexibility. Having a high count of ramp
is also quite helpful since the deck has
a relatively high mana commander that's
central to its game plan. And always
having the mana to replay her kind of
lets me avoid needing to think too hard
about how consistent my alternate
windcons are. Despite this effort, there
are still ongoing challenges here. Some
sub themes just don't really have cards
that are good on their own or which tie
to other themes. Selelesnia eulogist and
rootcast apprenticeship are both
somewhat subpar interaction if I don't
have token copies and the two non-clock
untapping effects are both fairly
restrictive in their effect even if
their ceiling is high. And that's to say
nothing of the graveyard package. I
might have made it sound like I had the
problem of not enough cards for
dollhouse to reanimate and I solved it
by adding four or five graveyard
enablers, but honestly it still feels
like barely enough. The card still runs
out of useful stuff to copy pretty
regularly. In addition, there's another
card I want to add to this deck. God
Pharaoh's Gift has a higher upfront
cost, but is otherwise pretty similar to
Dollhouse of Horrors, making token
copies of creatures in graveyard by
exiling them. This is another one of my
favorite cards, but it currently makes
no sense at all here. It' have the same
problems as Dollhouse in not having
enough targets to copy, and it doesn't
even tie into the tap on tap, liquid
metal, or construct sub themes like
Dollhouse does. There are two problems
with the graveyard package. currently
only six cards that put cards into the
yard at the moment and only 23 total
creatures in the deck. It's kind of
discouraging to do the math on this. If
I've gone through 20 cards of my deck,
I've only seen four or five creatures.
And the number of those that have made
their way to the graveyard is almost
certainly less than that. Current goals
for the deck are increasing the creature
count, finding a third tutor for the
deck that alleviates some current
challenges, and possibly flushing out
other packages as well. My maybe board
on Architect goes kind of crazy. I have
four different categories of possible
additions within the maybe board in
addition to a more generic category. If
you have ideas for how to cram more deck
into this deck, please let me know. I'd
genuinely love to hear them. It's funny
when I think about what advice I'd give
if somebody else presented this deck to
me saying they wanted to make it better
because the answer is obviously please
cut some sub themes. You have way too
many of them. Why am I spending deck
space on tap on tap cards other than
Clock of Omens? Why am I going to the
effort of a copy populate package? Why
am I bothering to integrate graveyard
synergies into this? Why am I even
thinking about our aristocratless
aristocrats? A sensible player trying to
improve this would cut most of the
graveyard support, at least two of the
populate cards and all of the token copy
cards aside from Nexus of Becoming. But
that's the joy of this deck to me. I
shouldn't be doing what I'm doing if I
wanted a deck that plays smoothly. And
the fact that I'm doing it anyway is
what makes this a bracket 2 deck. It's
the same reason this deck includes some
kind of not great proliferate cards.
Would a sensible player trying to
upgrade this deck include Plaguema
Beast, Carnivorous Canopy, and Spread
the Sickness? Probably not, but it's not
like I'm going to be playing these
flavorful cards anywhere else. And here,
they're fine. They feel acceptable, and
that's pretty cool if you ask me. Thanks
for watching. I talked a bit about my
skeleton ship deck in this video, and if
you want to know more about that, I
posted a short video for supporters
discussing that deck, its play patterns,
its pitfalls, and some of the dumbest
games I had with it. If you want the
full version, you can join my Patreon or
become a YouTube member, but there will
be a sneak preview for it in about 10
seconds. I also released an older patron
video about my original Glista deck over
on my second channel with some included
commentary of why I swapped it out for a
new deck, so you can also check that
out. With that said, it's time to enter
the bone zone.
I find skeleton ship very funny in the
sense that it's from the era of Magic
where somebody would go, "Well, of
course you need an island in play. It's
a ship." I actually intentionally ran a
somewhat low count of islands just so
I'd occasionally not have one and get to
go, "Ah, shoot. I can't cast my ship
yet." Though, realistically, this wasn't
actually shooting myself in the foot
because I didn't cast my commander most
games, even when I had an island out.
There was simply always something better
I could be doing with my mana than
spending five of it on a very slow
removal